welcome to this video playing pogo boy
and aah oh boy and that's a totally new
account let's see trying the Kings
Indian okay this line I play similar
stuff mostly with the night shot already
on or near three really thinking long
here in situ is a stranger booth here
okay that's not try to refute everything
that looks strange and just and try to
play a bit quicker maybe you can take on
c5 take e5 could be possible yeah it's
very rarely a good idea but with the
night on this Bishop on this seven maybe
it is
it's played a 15 minute game and the
sole account looks very very fishy
Bishop takes e5 and this is not really a
move that a good player would play so
this is very strange unless you have a
very concrete goal and here why didn't
didn't follow up with anything anything
serious
he's spending lots of time that's a very
strange game now with the knight on d6 I
mean in really good shape
should I go ahead fire maybe
mm before yeah maybe come on it's it's
not the best move probably but I have I
have an easy plan at least after that
g5g for me after Queenie to g5 Knight f3
blunders the Queen shouldn't do that
I don't need to play a four just yet to
block it's not enough nothing threatened
at the moon I want to play King g7 mu k
jg v g4 yeah i don't know what but
something is off here in this game
queenie took when you want a very human
way to play and leave
but also cannot really be a computer
because it's just so weak what is
playing even if a computer's white is
not understanding the position it's it's
a very weird very weird way what's
happening here is such a TIA
oh dear I really don't know it was a
very very weird game and it looked very
strange
don't don't really know what what to
make of it yeah I know I'm a bit I'm a
bit I'm a bit adult dumbfounded about
this the only point of the smoothness is
to take I mean maybe maybe white can
take maybe I can play this down
check and and black is okay interesting
honey line but but this way I'm I'm in
excellent shape
and very quickly we get a the totally
one-sided position it's quite funny that
that stock fish is not understanding
this position at all
it gives white a slight edge which is
which is of course totally ridiculous
yeah I mean you can argue okay other
computer stronger than me blah blah blah
it is but how is white going to show
anything if I just stay here Queen e7
and shuffle White has no plan here in
this position he can never ever be
better okay anyway and Queen e2 the
squiggly one Queen e2 Peck was really
strange and him I took some time here
but it it is it is a total devastation
yeah a strange game how to hard to to
evaluate yeah thanks for watching